the long-awaited adaptation of Alan
Moore's graphic novel Batman The Killing
Joke has finally arrived I saw this
movie yesterday night at a fathom event
screening packed theater tons of Batman
fans there it was really cool if you
know anything about Batman The Killing
Joke you know that it is Batman and the
Joker and a confrontation between the
two where the Joker wants to prove to
Batman that any average person can go
insane just like he asks so there was a
humongous amount of anticipation for
this movie for one Mark Hamill has
returned to voice the Joker Kevin Conroy
has returned to voice Batman and it's
the first DC animated film to ever
receive a rated R rating it's also one
of the most beloved graphic novels of
all time The Killing Joke is humongously
popular I love it I've read it multiple
times I've read Batman comics most my
whole life and so whenever an adaptation
like this comes along there's also a
part of me that's very reserved and
afraid because it's so beloved and it's
so anticipated that it's difficult to
live up to said hype in this case there
are aspects of this movie that I enjoyed
and aspects that I really didn't enjoy
and a few things that really confuse me
choices that were made that just didn't
make sense to me and don't worry if you
never read the graphic novel I won't
spoil anything for you it is a quick
read though I recommend it it's very
very very good Alan Moore you know him V
for Vendetta
this guy's talented check it out
sometime things I liked obviously Mark
Hamill and Kevin Conroy are fantastic
with their voice work I love Tara Strong
the voice of Batgirl they are so very
talented what they do and they just feel
so iconic every time you see these
animated characters and those voices
coming out of it that was obviously a
joy to hear and see there were a lot of
scenes that are directly from the
graphic novel scenes that are 100%
word-for-word from the graphic novel and
the panel's very well recreated in this
film those scenes were very suspenseful
very tense and very well done and all of
those scenes that are directly from the
graphic novel that are clearly inspired
by said graphic novel are fantastic and
are great recreations of those events
now I understand that whenever you're
adapting something whether it be a book
or a TV series or a comic book there are
going to be changes certain things are
going to be in the source material that
you just can't put in the movie because
of time constraints or something else
and this doesn't bother me I understand
that when you adapt something certain
changes have to
made when you see my upcoming Harry
Potter reviews you're going to
understand that's not something that
bothers me but I do have a bit of a
guideline that I like to follow and that
guideline is that if you're going to
change something at least improve it and
in this case there is an entire first
act added of about 30 minutes of Batman
and Batgirl chasing down criminals and
his one crime boss has a fetish for
Batgirl and is after her and there's a
lot of time dedicated to this an absurd
amount of time so much time in fact that
I was beginning to think that they were
Gareth Edwards in Batman if you've ever
seen the new Godzilla film which I do
like you know that Godzilla really isn't
in that movie too much and every time
he's about to do something cool they pan
away or they go to a next scene they do
that a lot in the first act of this
movie with Batman to focus on Batgirl
and I understand
again no spoilers so you've never read
the graphic novel that they were trying
to flesh out her character to make you
feel more attached to her for this movie
to make her a little more emotionally
developed than she is in the novel
unfortunately the way they go about it I
just didn't think it added much to this
movie and in the long run I don't know
if someone's made this joke yet but this
movie kind of felt like Batgirl The
Killing Joke I mean it even opens with
Batgirl actually narrating to the
audience I know this is not the
beginning you thought you were going to
see I'm like no not it's definitely not
you're right I mean you can actually see
the part in the movie where it becomes
the movie you wanted to see where it
fades out after that first act and fades
into the first few panels of The Killing
Joke you're like okay this is the movie
I wanted to see why didn't this happen
at the beginning I don't know there's
there's certain things in this movie
that just didn't have to be there in
regards to adding and putting things in
all these little side scenes that just
felt like they were trying to elongate
something when they didn't really have
to I mean if you want to make a killing
joke animated film and make it be 45
minutes and just have it be really tight
suspenseful and contained make it 45
minutes you don't have to add an extra
30 minutes of Batgirl and Batman
swinging around the city it has
absolutely nothing to do with The
Killing Joke
quite literally nothing it is just there
to flesh out the character of Barbara
Gordon but my biggest issue with this
movie is kind of a gray area because
this was originally supposed to be
straight to blu-ray and DVD and so the
animation is very much so straight to
blu-ray and DVD quality seeing
a giant Cinemark XD screen last night
did not do much for the animation in
this movie there are certain scenes that
are very well animated and then there
are some that are truly awful what I
don't understand is when movies like
Akira and ghost in the shell' that came
out 20 years ago that maybe admittedly
had bigger budgets have such better
beautiful hand-drawn animation than this
it's unclear to me as to why that
happened because this is such a beloved
graphic novel it got a theatrical
release because of its popularity you
got Mark Hamill and Kevin Conroy Mark
Hamill is huge right now because a Star
Wars Episode 7 in Star Wars Episode 8
they should have gotten a much better
budget and much better animation for
this movie but in the end the voice work
and the aspects of this movie that
directly attributed an honored said
graphic novel were the best parts of
this movie I would love to say that the
additions and the changes actually added
something but they unfortunately did not
for me it didn't really give much extra
emotion and it just felt like tacked on
scenes I'm going to give Batman The
Killing Joke a C+ in my humble opinion
there is no reason this should have been
any less than really good when you have
Mark Hamill reprising his role as the
Joker and you have Kevin Conroy as
Batman and Alan Moore's excellent source
material and this much fan anticipation
and a theatrical release because of how
excited people are this should have been
so much better than it is guys those are
my thoughts on Batman The Killing Joke I
would highly recommend reading the
graphic novel I don't necessarily think
you have to run out and see this movie
if you get a chance to see it on blu-ray
at home that's probably a better place
to do it
I'm seeing Jason Bourne later today look
forward to the continuation and finale
of our Jason Bourne skits also I want to
give a humongous thank you to Amazon
Prime music for sponsoring this video
and supporting my channel if you go to
Amazon songs of summer dot-com slash
Chris you can listen to the entire songs
of summer playlist that's Amazon songs
of summer dot-com slash Chris prime
music is a free benefit included with
the Prime membership with prime music
you can listen ad free to over a million
songs from top artists and more music is
added all the time you can listen to
anywhere on multiple devices like Amazon
echo Fire devices iPad iPhone Android
tons of free music there to listen to
it's hot outside and summer it's time to
kick back
have some fun listening to some this
great music like the strum Bellas summer
of 69 is a song that I've always really
enjoyed definitely check out Amazon
songs of summer dot-com slash Kris you
guys are the best thank you so much as
always for watching and thank you to
Amazon for sponsoring my videos it is a
big help to me and I thank you very much
for that as well you guys are the best
thank you once again if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes